[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola
queriendo estar acá
para arrancar me gustaría que
reflexionemos un poco juntos sobre qué
es la percepción
la percepción es la manera en la cual
nuestros sentidos captan la información
que nos da el entorno luego nuestro
cerebro procesa y forma nuestra mirada
del mundo
lo sorprendente de esto es que tenemos
la posibilidad de elegir cómo queremos
ver nuestro mundo
y como actuamos en base a lo que en él
sucede solo basta
con tener
una mente de principiante
esta trata de no perseguir lo
extraordinario
sino abrirse a experimentar plenamente
el ordinario
ahora los invito a que recorramos juntos
una parte de mi vida en la cual empecé a
mirar distintos
cambio mi mirada y también amplíe mi
mapa
y me tomé en serio lo de ampliar mi mapa
con un amigo de la infancia
empezamos entusiasmarnos ya terminando
con la secundaria
con la idea de irnos de viaje está idea
de irnos afuera a explorar lugares
totalmente distintos a lo que estábamos
acostumbrados nos parecía genial
tu paso muy rápido y entre despedidas y
dejar un poquito de lado la familia los
amigos la rutina party para nueva
zelanda donde comenzó mi viaje hacia el
desconocido
apenas llegué tuve las primeras
impresiones de lo que iba a ser ese
viaje el ya no depender de nadie sino de
las propias ganas de hacer algo empezar
a decidir por mí solo dónde ir qué hacer
y de qué manera manejar la situación
la primera parada fue el norte vivimos
tres meses
en un hostel que fue el peor hostel que
experimenté en todo el viaje
pero a la vez el mejor el mejor
por lo que hay aprendí y por la gente
que ahí conocí
cuándo
y va pasando el tiempo me iba dando
cuenta que cuando te despejas un poquito
de lo que ya frecuenté para vos
abriéndote a las nuevas experiencias y
conectando realmente con las personas
las relaciones se empiezan a dar con
mucha más intensidad de la que estaba
acostumbrado
fuimos moviéndonos de lugar en lugar
conociendo paisajes preciosos y
compartiendo nuestra vida con gente que
quizá en nuestra virtualidad no lo
haríamos pero no por no querer sino
por ir en automático
olvidando que en el fondo todos tenemos
las mismas ganas y las mismas energías
buscamos lo mismo
en el medio de nuestro paso por nueva
zelanda se nos dio por conocer un país
muy diferente al que estábamos indonesia
esto era otra vez dejar de lado todo en
lo que ya nos sentíamos cómodos pero
valió la pena el riesgo
la cultura en asia es totalmente
distinta a la que estamos acostumbrados
de este lado del planeta
desde el idioma hasta cómo preparar un
plato de comida toda esta experiencia me
fueron mostrando que realmente hay
millones de maneras de vivir la vida
sólo con estar predispuesto puedes tomar
las que más te importen a vos
volvimos a nueva zelanda y ahí me
esperaban visitas mis padres venían a
acompañarme en mi viaje
todavía no me toca volver a mi lugar
pero era como que mi lugar venía a
viajar conmigo un poquito
recordándome
que toda mi vida antes del viaje
también era parte de la experiencia
la visita se fue y había que volver a
vivir solo otra vez esta vez en la parte
sur empezamos a trabajar en un tambo con
jornadas intensas y cansado horas de
trabajo pero nada que la recompensa de
aprender nuevas cosas
y tener el dinero rápido para irnos de
vuelta de viaje no compense
un día como era normal me levanté a las
3 de la mañana a ordeñar el primer lote
de vacas las orden y ahí me fui a
desayunar con un amigo uruguayo nos
tocaba hacer una tarea que era juntarlos
terneritos recién nacidos y llevarlos a
sus establos
a ese día a mi amigo le tocó manejar la
camioneta yo estaba parado
en el enganche que va
desde la camioneta hasta el tráiler que
estaba cargado de terneros
el día anterior había llovido nosotros
trabajábamos en botas y estaba el pasto
mojado
yo estaba parada en ese enganche con
total seguridad haciendo la tarea como
siempre con cierta diversión
de repente no sé cómo pero me caigo
lo que tiene hacer mi cerebro en unos
milisegundos es pensar en dos cosas la
primera es quedarme en el medio para que
no me pisen las ruedas y la segunda fue
cubrirme la cabeza
imagínense lo rápido que fue todo que no
tuve tiempo ni de gritar de un momento
para el otro estaba tirado boca arriba
mirando como la camioneta del tráiler
seguían su camino sin entender mucho
aunque no lo crean yo digo que tuve
suerte
todas las posibilidades
que hasta el día de hoy me imagino que
podrían haber pasado debajo de ese
trailer
son más oscuras que la que me tocó vivir
esto me sirvió
para darme cuenta
realmente que estar vivo
es un regalo
cuando mi amigo uruguayo se da cuenta
que me había caído se bajó y vino
corriendo
yo lo primero que intente hacer fue
levantarme intenté y ese solo intento me
basto para saber que estaba complicado
no estaba sintiendo las piernas
las primeras palabras con mi amigo
uruguayo fueron un poco desesperadas
tiene algunas de esas agonías que solo
se ven en las películas 'el y bueno
ahora se termina todo
dios esperame
creo que fue un buen pibe
no sé por lo menos me voy en una
situación épica
lo único malo es no tener al lado a la
gente de toda la vida pero bueno los
llamo y ahí mi cabeza hizo la primera
pausa
fermín yo no te muevas mucho porque
estamos complicados y algo muy
importante no llames a tus viejos
porque en parte me sentía con fuerzas
ahí empezó a funcionar la mente positiva
y la focalización tratando de entrar en
razón entremedio de todo el ruido y los
problemas que llevan a mi cabeza muy
rápido
entre muchas cosas negativas que pensaba
como
me vuelvo argentina se me termina el
viaje en una semana nace mi sobrino y
van a tener que venir mis viejos mira
cuando me viene a pasar esto a mí
y ahí fue cuando paré a pensar y empecé
a hacer le dije a mi amigo uruguayo que
llama el jefe de la granja que llamen a
la ambulancia que llame al amigo de la
infancia que me traiga ropa mi mochila
pasaporte que venga porque teníamos para
ratos
esto me enseñó que parar a pensar cuando
el ruido es ensordecedor
muchas veces
puede hacer la diferencia
en esto
sí
el peor miedo que yo tenía era no
contarla
lo más curioso es que acá apareció en mi
cabeza lo conocido que no era
necesariamente la realidad en la que
estaba pero pensaba estoy en el medio
del campo la ambulancia no va a poder
llegar tengo una hora hasta que venga
una hora para llegar al hospital
christopher menchov despedirte la
realidad es que todo se fue envolviendo
muy rápido en unos pocos minutos
me había buscado en helicóptero y
llevado
al lugar donde me van a operar
la situación límite y de emergencia ya
había pasado ya estaba en un hospital de
primer mundo cuidado por buenos
profesionales
y ya me habían operado
al día siguiente una mañana tranquila
muy temprano todavía mis amigos no
habían llegado estaba solo se acercó un
médico muy correcto
me hace un par de testigos un par de
preguntas y se va
al rato vuelve con un enfermero y en
inglés con una tonada rara me dice
no sé con quién estarás
no sé quién te estará acompañando
pero vos no vas a volver a caminar nunca
más
y vi como toda mi vida
se iba a pique
toda mi forma de vivirla desaparecía en
un segundo
tuve que asimilar eso y entremedio de la
terrible noticia decidí no centrar la
atención en lo que me había dicho ese
médico había una realidad
y era que había una lesión medular
importante
pero estaba convencido que no eran mis
límites nadie sabía cómo iba a ser mi
proceso de rehabilitación
darme cuenta que la decisión estaba en
mí
fue lo que me ayudó a seguir
pasaron los primeros días y yo estaba
más tranquilo y acompañado mi padre
había ido a acompañarme y ya estaba con
mis amigos
me pasaron a un hospital especializado
en médula espinal donde iba a pasar por
un proceso de volver a vivir de una
manera que hasta el momento desconocía
los primeros meses fueron muy duros
porque mi cuerpo empezó a experimentar
todos los cambios asociados con la
lesión esto me generaba mucho dolor y
malestar
al cuerpo le lleva tiempo entender qué
le pasa
y yo a medida que iba transcurriendo ese
tiempo iba aprendiendo sobre mí
conociéndome
y asimilando todas las posibles secuelas
o síntomas que podía llegar a tener
el último mes de rehabilitación
fue la más fue distinto porque yo tenía
que empezar a proponerme en mis propios
objetivos
entre los más marcados estaban volverá a
ser independiente volver a mi casa para
las fiestas y volverá al deporte pero
había uno que me daba vueltas y vueltas
por la cabeza porque lo creía imposible
volverá al mar
se me hacía difícil imaginarme en una
playa en silla de ruedas con todas las
ruedas trabajadas intentando tirarme al
agua y hacer lo que tanto me gustaba
cuando podía surfear
en rehabilitación me mostraron que se
podía hacer deportes como el básquet
adaptado que hoy en día práctico y a
pesar del alocada que podía llegar a
sonar la idea de surfear volvió a
hacerlo una experiencia increíble
antes de empezar a lamentarme por algo
que quizás no voy a poder hacer nunca
más
ya le estaba volviendo a hacer
el proceso de rehabilitación fue
llegando a su fin yo ya estaba preparado
para volver a mi vida a mi vida ahora
distinta ya que nadie va a ser como
antes
pude concretar mi anhelo de volver a mi
casa para las fiestas para pasarlo con
mi amigos y mi familia
siempre es lindo volver
pero theron volver distinto a un lugar
conocido pero desconocido a la vez con
muchas cosas para asimilar yo mi familia
y mis amigos
la vuelta a 1 haber modificado y ahora
adaptado
que mi madre se había quedado resignando
sus ganas de ir a verme para tenerlo
listo para mi regreso conocer un mundo
nuevo en una ciudad que ya conocía de
arriba a abajo cómo era la vida del
deporte adaptado en la argentina y las
adaptaciones en las ciudades
que cuando uno no está cerca de alguien
que está en silla no las conoce
a mí se me empleó el mundo
mundo
en el que estaba encerrado en una
burbuja de amigos de siempre lugares de
siempre y rutina
mundo que estaba ahí solo que yo no lo
conocía y no era porque no quería
simplemente no estaba en mi esquema
yo creo
que para ampliar nuestro mapa solo
necesitamos prestar atención en aquellas
pequeñas cosas del día a día
que están ahí a nuestro lado y muchas
veces pasamos por alto
y están ahí sólo necesitamos enfocar
nuestros sentidos para poder perseguir
las
sin necesidad de pasar por una situación
que nos obliga a hacerlo
hay una frase que alguien me dijo y
guarde todo este viaje me gustaría
compartirla con ustedes
a partir de ahora solo te van a pasar
cosas buenas
hay algo claro y es que nosotros no
podemos decidir las cosas que nos pasen
ni elegir que todas ellas sean buenas
lo que sí podemos decidir
es mirar distinto cambiar nuestra
percepción para siempre encontrar lo
bueno de lo que nos pase y poder
aprender de ello
mi invitación es a que aprovechen esa
oportunidad que tenemos todos los días
de mirar distinto
sin necesidad de vernos obligados a
hacerlo muchas gracias
[Aplausos]